all right we're still alive
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go
you hear that that is every night by
Jamison Jamison flood is the man's name
and he sent that in and well I
appreciate that music submission there's
beautiful music there you know that
sound like somebody's getting you know
somebody uh getting you know molested by
a stream or something maybe in Montana
[Music]
you know this sound like somebody's
trying to uh somebody's hitting on your
mother at a bar while you're you know
nine years old and you're just you know
waiting over by the by the cigarette
machine you know beating on it like it's
a video game and trying to find
something to do
[Music]
a lot of mustaches a lot of mustaches
back behind that music and that's
Jameson flood that's what that is and I
appreciate appreciate that sound right
there thank you guys for joining us on
this past weekend it is Monday January
29 in the year two thousand one eight
and we are in the realm of the universe
as far as we know and they say I was
here in somewhere the other day that we
might be figments of our own imagination
we might be somebody else's plan we
might be somebody else's video game and
I'm like damn bruh
you know if that's the case man get that
uh get that mushroom and let Daddy
sprout you know if that's the case then
get that flashy flower cuz I'm ready to
throw some fireballs you know I'm ready
to wing a couple of flaming pop pops at
[ __ ] locals you know that's what I'm
ready to do I mean sometimes we just man
I wish you had fireballs wouldn't it be
awesome
somebody's talking or something and they
won't shut it down and you've been
listening and you've been a patient
listener probably for maybe already
probably a minute in 10 seconds and
that's about my listen spam where they
need to give a break for somebody else
to kind of pop in a 70 second mark and
if they just keep running past over two
minutes oh I just just winged a damn
just just a little just a flaming little
[ __ ] nugget right at them take one of
their earlobes off show them who's boss
show them who's boss and this is talk
and listen and fight and it's talking
listen association oh sorry man I'm just
a little frustrated you know when
sometimes you are sometimes you are just
a little frustrated that's okay what's
going on welcome thank you guys for
joining me thank you guys for being here
thank you for being alive you know I had
a pretty wild weekend I'll get into that
fur
I got a new bed you know I got a new bed
you know the old bed not that good of
luck you know I had this bed probably
for maybe three years not a lot of sex
in it not a lot of good sex that's for
sure definitely a lot of awkward kind of
laying there you know talking about why
you know the sex wasn't good or why you
know you know had that pti the Pte that
part-time erection you know because my
erection boy the thing will file for
unemployment like a motherhood you know
my erection like to get that disability
check so you know that this bed hadn't
really seen it and also this bed it kind
of looked like a lute like ah I don't
want to say a lady's bed because that is
gutter you know for a man to be in a
lady's bed that's not the end he don't
have a lady and he's just laying in a
woman's bed at night that is just
something that is wild you know that's
something that is not for that's for
outdoors that's for another realm that's
not what's supposed to be happening in
my life and I got this bed and it was
like one of those was like a wrought
iron kind of you know had that kind of
cagey sort of kind of a British it
looked kind of British you know kind of
like two really skinny people that were
in Britain like a man and a woman or two
men you know that are that are married
this isn't I'm kind of bad we're like
two men that just are getting together
to do sex meet up they sit in a bed like
that this is a two men that have been
married and have a couple of you know
armoires and maybe you know a lot of
fancy books in another room a rug you
know it's something more like that or
were two real thin women would meet up
and and be with each other you know and
be around each other like that so yeah
anyway I got rid of that and I got me a
more of a wooden bed and this thing is a
damn Noah's Ark
that it could weigh 700 pounds I don't
even know I mean it just I don't know I
mean it it took your Gyptians to get it
into the house that's how heavy this
thing was so I got a new bed you know
those are pretty good I think if this
company called Blake Avenue you know and
I don't work with them or yeah Blake
Avenue dot-com they got cool wooden beds
because I started seeing this every bed
I would look for it's all the same bed
or the same five or six beds they're all
sold by the same three or four companies
over stock or Wayfarer or [ __ ] you
know sleep [ __ ] or whatever you know
and I wanted something that was a little
more unique you know a genuine bed you
know because I've slept in some unique
spots before you know I slept under a
man's bed when I first moved out here to
Los Angeles and that was a non-central
relationship that was friendship only
and for $150 a month I slept under his
bed and I had whooping cough tutor in
that time and I had to hold my coffee in
one time while he was making love to a
woman or or he may have actually just
been masturbating but also in person
doing impressions of a woman at the same
time so I don't know what was going on
but one of those things was going on and
I had a whooping coffee if you don't
know whooping cough sometimes you feel
like you have to call sometimes a coffee
'ls like it has to you and that's what
pink off whooping cough is like that
it's that brother that shows up or that
that that rednecky dude that shows up
and don't ask you any questions and just
punches you in in the [ __ ] face and
that's whooping cough and that thing
beat me down beat me up and beat me up
and down and that's what happened to me
but I got a new bed what else I get up
Saturday morning I was gonna do some
volunteering at the Special Olympics you
know I met this girl you know that I met
a plus-size model a while back you know
and uh you know you know what plus-size
model this a girl that likes to eat and
you know eating uh and you know and look
fancying and I like that because I like
to do those things sometimes I like to
eat and be a little bit fancy and so she
told me that
you got to do this she said she had a
family member I think I was in the
Special Olympics I was like I you know I
want to go and check it out and she said
that she volunteered all the time so I
checked it out so I went down there
Saturday morning I get there
8:00 a.m. turns out the thing was on
Friday so I'm down there asking people
just dude it not even hadn't been down
there's more this is at a high school
down near Long Beach you know about a
40-minute drive I get there I'm asking
people you know have you seen the
Special Olympics and people looking at
me like um you know should be a coach in
it you know it should be a damn you know
should be running the fourth leg of the
relay because I'm running around this
school in this track and everything
looking for Special Olympians and asking
people and it turns out finally I go
back and look at the documentation
they'd sent me in this [ __ ] the thing
was on Friday the thing was on Friday
and how about this who-who does a
Special Olympics on Friday huh
Special Olympics is a weekend event you
don't put a Special Olympics on a Friday
so those those these young warriors and
battlers and you know javelin errs the
you know who are you know I have some
afflictions some of God's favorites and
they got to be out there and traffic on
a Friday and mucking around and people
can't go watch them so now I'm sitting
down in Long Beach at 8:30 I'm soaked
I'm furious
you know I'm furious because you know I
wanted to go I was excited I had a late
night the night before at work I got up
early I got in the car I got down there
and I mean I was I was bummed that I'd
missed it because I wanted to be there I
wanted to do it
you know I was working registration
there gonna be fun was gonna be
something I'd never been to before
because I've never even been to a
regular Olympics you know I met Picabo
Street one time in Utah and honestly
brush she seemed down
you know Picabo Street seemed like she
didn't she wouldn't mind if I - uh done
a couple of u-turns in the cul-de-sac
you know but um and I remember one time
I got to head this skeleton course out
there at the Olympic was in Utah I
didn't go to the Olympics but I got to
go to the training facility and they had
the skeleton and that's where you lay
face-first on this little bitty it's
almost like a just a window like
somebody took a window out of a building
and set it on the ground on an ice track
and you just go as fast as you can and
you're your face is just three inches
from the ice man that's a that [ __ ] was
Hardy that's it was scary but uh but
anyhow so now I'm furious I'm furious
I guess I'm angry that my time is you
know I feel like I've wasted my time
even though it's just it's not even you
know the time was even about me is about
being there for you know the program
what was going on and and next thing you
know I'm just I had to go park by the
water I did go park by the water in my
car and just take some deep breaths cuz
I was then I was angry because I was
also angry why you do Special Olympics
on a Friday because you don't know what
Friday is like in Los Angeles
sorry Friday in Los Angeles and that's
Jameson flood right there who sent in
his music and he just emailed me back
and said it is not copy written and so
we can use that
so thank that thank you there we'll put
a link to his soundcloud in the in the
in the YouTube and that was this song
earlier which sounds like you know like
somebody's you know taking off your
stepmothers shirt and is basically just
spending a disco ball around between her
tits and blowing a cigarette smoke
around her neck and maybe up around her
thighs and stuff here yeah
[Music]
and that's what that is right there so
all right I'm sorry my audio was low I
didn't realize that guys and now I'm
coming in now flexing a little bit I had
the wrong audio yeah man
I just feel like you ever had those
times nothing's going your way nothing's
going your way I wish somebody would
pull up with a damn van full of your way
and just [ __ ] dump that [ __ ] all over
my body
because sometimes I want things to go my
way so yeah that's why I was I was out
there and so now I'm parked by the water
cuz I'm pissed I'm pissed for one that
I'm up that I'm down there that it's not
going on that I missed it I'm pissed
that I didn't read the documentation
properly and then I'm also angry that
they do Special Olympics on a Friday and
and I'm not even in them you know Here I
am angry about something that has
nothing to even do with me so that was
that was pretty much kind of the
highlight of my weekend you know I hit a
couple of men's meeting as a couple of
you know of the sobriety kind and did a
little bit of that and what else I am
I'll try to watch a little bit of that
b-movie it's about bees with Jerry
Seinfeld and I actually met a beekeeper
one time off of casual encounters and
this is back when casual encounters was
pretty popular and that was a place
where people that didn't know each other
could meet up with each other blindly
for sex or just for a friendship or even
to [ __ ] see some bee hives and I was
out in where was I I don't know
somewhere maybe Oh Missouri and this gal
and I got invited to I met this gal of
casual encounters because I used to be
out in the minister Dark Arts when you
got there in the depths of the web you
know meeting up with strangers just to
you know to have some sort of a
connection and I wouldn't know how you
know not and it wasn't always you were
trying to meet up for some type of a
sensuality so no you're just meeting up
to Tim to see somebody you know because
you're out in these city some of you by
yourself and so I met up with this lady
and she was a dying beekeeper and she
drove a truck she drove a man's truck
and so you know it made me a little
nervous when a woman drives a man's
truck because you know what sometimes
comes along with a man's truck a man so
I didn't want to get involved with that
but she took me out to the beekeeping
range where she kept bees and and I got
to and I got to put on the suit and do a
little bit of that you know that smoke
work you know blowing that smoke you
know blowing that smoke all around and
getting those bees chill calming them
bees down because bees are just like us
they obviously want the legalization of
marijuana no bees want to you know with
if that smoke hits them they chill out
you know it's like a I mean basically
what you do for bees is you create a
little hookah lounge and then they're so
chill and calm you steal all their honey
you steal all that [ __ ] butts sweet
that they make because that's what they
do do they spin and honey right another
butt and that is damn remarkable imagine
that imagine if we could do that you
find a baby who's got a full diaper and
then you just damn sweeten the cake
batter with it I mean that would be
God's playing right there what are we
even talking about I don't know I don't
know sometimes I don't know I uh what
else happened this weekend yeah I guess
just I don't know Joe there's been
thinking a lot about my own ego and
trying not to try to do anything I could
think of that would help keep my ego
down you know having an ego is scary
having this thing inside of you that
just once for yourself
scary I mean it's you know at a certain
point in our lives and as human beings
I'm sure ego probably you know we needed
it more when we had more when we had to
survive more I mean now it's like you
have to really mess up I mean you have
to get to some low levels to not survive
especially in America you know other
countries they'll leave you out down the
road you know you'll turn into it in
India you'll be a [ __ ] speed bump in a
week and a half dear you'll be people
will be driving over you and no excuses
that's it you know it's over your life
will end like that some of these other
countries but in America you can keep
going
you can keep cruising in the US of A
you know and they'll keep giving your
programs and sit assistance assistance
and wet in welfare and double welfare
and triple welfare and no whammies no
whammies no whammies welfare vacation
you know we just keep giving it in some
places people need it and sometimes
people don't you know but we'll get you
know I don't know man I don't know what
else you know I was thinking about this
week and I was thinking about when I was
young they had you know I'm pretty
gullible and when I was young they had a
time where I didn't talk to my mother
for probably about a year and a half and
we had they had a man called my school
and ended up sending me an email and
this is when they had email and a man
sent me an email and it was my turned
out to be my great uncle you know and I
don't even know how many greater you
know like I mean my father was 70 years
old when I was born a lot of you guys
know that and so my dad was born in 1910
so the great uncle you know I'm keyed up
I mean I'm intrigued to see what's going
on you know and who knows how I mean he
wasn't like a hundred and something
years old but he's older man so I met up
with him he was nice and then my
girlfriend I had a girlfriend at the
time so we'd go over there and spend
some time with him hang out you know
have some snacks or something or maybe
listen to some music some adult music
and then he one time started getting us
a little bit cooked up on buying us some
marijuana and liquor apple cider liquor
you know and we you know we have a good
little time hanging out and then one
time I got real high and he melt what
they called him uncle melt like you know
something that was frozen one time and
now it's not like that melt and he would
uh he tried to hook up with my
girlfriend and at first I thought oh man
I'm just high dude I'm so [ __ ] high
that I think that this that my uncle
great uncle's trying to bang
check and I don't know if we were
banging so I mean that's pretty ballsy
of them you know I mean it's nice of
them to assume that I'm making that I'm
getting sex but it's also kind of [ __ ]
up to of him if I'm not to think I'm
gonna let him bang my girlfriend first
before I get to bang her
you know I'm stung I'm working towards
those sexual goals you know as a child
and so anyway I thought I was like damn
I'm so [ __ ] high dude I think this
old dudes tryin to [ __ ] my girlfriend
and I'm like this [ __ ] is this some
killer weed you know cuz I've been
around me I was home with some weed one
time when I couldn't uh bend my legs one
time and wouldn't have been bad but I
was standing up when I started smoking
if I'd have been sittin down no issue
you know but when I'm standing up
already and then I can't bend my legs
that's you know it was just hell dude
I'd have a friend of mine pick me up and
let me down and I've been high you know
you can't you don't know what's goin on
right but I had min I hadn't been high
well but like holy [ __ ] dude this old
dudes tryin to bang my lady and that's
some killer [ __ ] but turns out anyway
anyway fast forward my mom and I kind of
reconciled and and and and I didn't go
back over there much after that and then
my mom and I were talking one time and
you know I'm just telling her we're
talking about family and stuff and I'm
telling her about uncle melt and she
says she's like who and I'm like uncle
melt
you know melt and I guess I assumed it
was you know short for melting if that's
even if that's even a name now I don't
even know it doesn't sound like a name
now that I'm saying it melt and if I met
any money Melton no I don't know but
she's like you don't you don't she's
like what uncle melt and I'm describing
her she's like you don't even have an
uncle melt you don't have an uncle
Melton and I'm like holy [ __ ] dude
and that was it man so some dude I don't
even know found me somehow through the
school system hung out with me and my
girlfriend got us [ __ ] up trying to
bang my girlfriend like a senior citizen
dude that I don't even know so
you want to talk about the Special
Olympic we've all been out there and
some damn Special Olympics you know
we've all had some hurdles and some you
know some things some shotput some we've
had to get off our chests you know we've
all done some you know we've I mean I
remember the first time I ever did
cocaine man I wasn't running somebody
told me was a performance-enhancing drug
so next thing you know I'm out there on
a couple of grams that had white you
know or that fluff a duffel us bra all
that you know and next you know I ran
seven miles dude and a pair of orange um
bros out there in Baton Rouge Louisiana
near the railroad tracks high on cocaine
did I'd stop every Milan and cup up on
that dust and keep cruising that's where
I was at you know so we've all been
through some Olympics you know we've all
been through and I'm not knocking the
Special Olympics man because here's the
thing I'll tell you this if I know if I
had a heavy affliction you know if I had
a if I had a syndrome or something that
was real strong like that I don't know
that I would that I would be brave
enough to then compete I mean I'm afraid
to compete if my hair is a little off
you know I get nervous and
self-conscious if my DNA is a little bit
wrangled who even knows you know if I
got split ends on my TIGI ac cells or
whatever oh you know who knows who knows
if I'd be out there competing like a lot
of these brave women and men and
children hold on this cord just came out
I gotta put it back in all right what
else man I know this that gray block
pizza is our charter sponsor and if
you're in Los Angeles you go over to
18:11 Pico Boulevard
stop in and get daddy they got all that
magic boy they got them Bella goat they
got that picante foil they got
how deep so deep so go over there great
block pizza the link will be in the in
the in the comments and we're grateful
to them as well man I'm letting you guys
not be at Harveys in Portland next week
in Portland Oregon February 8th through
11th February 16th through 18th I'll be
in La Jolla at the Comedy Store 22nd
through the 24th february in Indio
California fantasy springs casino March
15th and 16th Tacoma comedy club
March 17th Spokane comedy club and April
6th and 7th Tampa Florida at Rock
Brothers brewing and everything is
available those are all available on the
on the website Theo van comm slash tour
t oh you are you I get this email you
know what you wanna know some kind of
[ __ ] I'm tired of man I get this email
the other day it says sign a petition
for people to stop taking selfies with
Tigers and this is an India I'm thinking
you know because that's Tiger country
Bali
you know Malaysia is somewhere where
there's a jungle because you ain't just
gonna find a tie you know you don't find
a tiger out there you know on a
basketball court you find a tiger on a
jungle and and this uh the in this
emails like you gotta sign this petition
we already have like 150,000 and I'm
like what what is his [ __ ] these are
Tigers dude okay and and this is it
might be a little bit of a messy
exchange over there wherever whatever
whatever second or third or maybe fourth
world country this is where some brave
person is next to a tiger and trying to
get the tiger to take a selfie with a
tourist but but but that's a huge
business probably there for them and we
don't have to have that business here
because we're pretty fortunate but that
dude or that lady has to have that
business you don't know how many people
are eating because that Tiger is out
there doing work you know it's like a
stripper in America
and you know I'll tell you when you want
to know when that Tiger when that Tiger
is ready to stop taking selfies that
tiger will let you know people out here
sign in a [ __ ] petition what are you
doing you want to go save a tiger go go
to go to your local strip club and pull
one of them pretty kittens offstage
because out that's the same exact thing
and you can say well it's not well it's
this well it's that it's not that's the
same thing somebody using something to
make money out there and you think
you're taking advantage drive over to
strip club let the bouncer let big Henri
and you know who's up who's probably a
big african-american man or a big white
guy with a neck tattoo let big Henry who
let big Henry see how he feels about
letting you take that tiger off stage
about getting that pretty passe down off
the stage man I don't even know dude
just one of those is it one of those
weeks I don't even know I don't even
know but that Alec how is that an issue
who's laying it that's your issue then
go over there wrassle it out go free
that tiger dude you seen that movie
where that boy ends up in a boat with
the tiger go take your chances
go take your chances with that cat
because that cat dude a tiger will lick
your skull open a tiger could I bet open
your skull just with the friction of his
tongue against your bone see you're out
here being lame you're out here being
like a dang jackass speaking of a
jackass man I'll tell you this little
news story the great donkey escape alone
donkey was found leading a herd of goats
and sheep through residential streets of
West Covina California after escaping
from a property in a neighboring City on
Thursday officers responded to the area
of Francisquito and
Linda around 12:30 a.m. after receiving
a call of a group of animals roaming a
neighborhood according to a post on the
West Covina Police Department's Facebook
page police discovered the donkey goats
and sheep slipped through an unsecured
gate from a property is this the script
to Madagascar I feel like I just read
the script to Madagascar but I would
guess honestly let's be let's be let's
think about this that that donkey was
probably down there doing some of those
sex shows and everybody thinks about the
lady you know but you want to go rescue
something said of people signing up to
take out can't you know go down to
Mexico just look in the donkey's eyes
and see if they are okay with making
love to these women you'll know the
animal will give you a look but
obviously they're not if this one's
heading north
you know this donkey probably running
out of there they should have checked
Steve had a couple condoms in his pocket
you know maybe it was that donkey but
things are going haywire right now I
guess this episode's hey why don't you
know what this episode is about but I
don't know what anything's about May and
I just been feeling for some reason I've
just been feeling testy I've been
feeling testy and I don't know why you
know I don't know why I've been trying
to stay calm and stay chill I got that
new bed that's the place I can rest you
know I just I guess I'm just nervous I
guess I'm just nervous about you know
some stuff going on I'm gonna try it out
for The Tonight Show sending a tape and
I didn't get it so that kind of
you know just made me feel I guess mmm I
don't know if it made me feel like I'm
not good enough as a comedian it just
made me feel you know what it made me
feel it made me feel that somebody
should start a Hollywood that creates
entertainment and not one that is just
in the business of of uh Holly was just
gotten so political I feel like you know
and not one that's just in the business
of entertaining advertisers you know and
a lot of people will say well look
you're not going to have the business if
you don't have the advertisers true but
I think that there's a great opportunity
out there right now for somebody to make
good entertainment to bring it along and
people will get on board because some of
the [ __ ] that's out there now man
there's some good stuff but damn dude I
don't know if I've ever seen as many bad
movies I saw recently everyone I just
come on well so anyway I guess ya just
made me feel you know it just made me
mad because some of the people that do
get on there and I'm not no discredit to
them but I know that I'm as good as some
of those comedians and uh and it's just
hard they don't you know you know they
it seems like you have a southern accent
oh you're from a certain place and a lot
of these a lot of these Hollywood
channels don't want to embrace your give
you an opportunity because you don't
just the sound of your voice makes them
think that you are not part of their
world are not good enough to be in their
world or just your accent er you know
you know even Hollywood pisses me off
man you know Hollywood's all about like
you know diversity and this and that now
two years ago blank people were had to
beg and boycott Hollywood to even get
Awards do you remember that two years
ago two years ago oh you know what I'm
gonna do right now then if I'm not
feeling good I'm gonna quit thinking
about myself and I'm gonna start
checking - some of these calls you guys
some calls that came in and I appreciate
them appreciate you guys putting up with
me today on this episode it's just kind
of it's just got a lot on the brain you
know as always if you have if you have
an issue you can hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and talk to us leave us a
voicemail if they're you're struggling
with something and you believe that
myself or someone else can offer some
basic life suggestions then then we'd
love to hear what's going on
again that numbers ninety five six six
four nine five zero three all right
let's listen to this call came in here
we go he brought up the government
shutdown it was real quick he stars had
good he's saying last week on last
week's episode I brought up the
government shutdown yes I did yep and I
said it was good I was glad the
government shutdown now if we could just
get the news media to shut down we might
be able to get a little bit of peace I
was kind of joking on word you'll be
fine you got a job I guess it's just
that I think you're you just didn't know
sort of a big point about it the reality
is that the people that shut it down
you know the Senators house those people
they still get paid they're still
working that whole time
their pay is actually permanently
authorized by the US Constitution so it
never stops Wow
I didn't know that so government
shutdown the big dog still get that feed
they still get that kibble in uh in in
Benjamin's homework what the people it
does affect you know those are people
like me it does stop for people like us
and we do start getting paid you know
like a little little about me and how it
affected me was I got a lot of bills you
know and basically I have nowhere I get
put on what all for a low and I'm
basically told a you're not getting the
paycheck you're not working you're gonna
have a job when it's over but who knows
on that's gonna be you know in 2013 it
was like three weeks I think to two
weeks um for the DoD it was a little
less because
work I do is considered mission-critical
okay wow so so you're saying that as a
as more of an all boots-on-the-ground
employee that you don't get paid yeah
you're right I didn't know that you know
I didn't know that I didn't know that
when government shut down like what
really occurs you know I didn't think
that a lot of people don't get paid you
know and I bet those probably a moment
for you when you're not getting paid
where you're starting to I bet it really
that's when you start feeling I bet like
what the [ __ ] is going on what's going
on in my country which who's making
these choices
I bet it's you know like not judging you
I mean I'm sorry to hear that
and I think that's [ __ ] you know I
don't think that people had vowed that
uh that serve in our military or who are
teachers I don't think it was people get
paid enough at all and I'm not grouping
those together because you know teachers
can't throw grenades but but I'm just
saying I've always thought that but I
bet there was a moment where once you
realize it that money you're not getting
paid I bet that makes you perk up you
know it makes you perk up when somebody
cuts those lifelines off you know the
like what you're do we know what we need
to survive that money when we need to to
you know to take care of ourselves to
pay our bills like you're talking about
makes you perk up it makes you see well
who's doing what who's not helping who's
not passing the laws or signing the
bills are you know and it seems these
days that a lot of it is ego with these
dip with these um political parties that
they're at the point where it's just ego
you know one of them doesn't what
doesn't want to help just because they
don't want to they personally don't want
to seem helpful and I think it's long
been that way but now it's just getting
more and more evident but I bet that you
you know what and I'm not trying to find
a silver lining in this for you but I'm
you know like I bet it's I bet that
that's when you get alive that you get
awakened to the fact that what the
[ __ ] really going on here because it's
not until we're affected really that's
that we that
we spruce up you know it's not until
we're affected that we you know he makes
you turn it makes you see what's going
on you know that's when you get alert
and so if we probably all need that we
probably all need a couple days where
somebody cut you know where we are
supply is cut and we got to look around
because we get you know we get a we get
comfortable on the tit in America and
that's even just the tit if we're just
working or what we're doing you know no
matter what we're doing we get
comfortable on the tit but I didn't know
that and I didn't know that our
congressmen and our senators senators
still get paid but I thank you for your
service man you're braver than I am
that's for sure I've always thought that
you guys should uh should get your vote
should count for a vote in a quarter of
vote and a half if you served in our
country I think you put more on the line
alright and last episode we had a man a
young man callin Jose Ochoa who was
calling asking about you know advice and
and questions as to if he was going to
he wanted to drop out of college
against his against one of his parents
wishes his stepfather I believe or his
father and he he wanted some suggestions
from us on that and I gave him a couple
of ideas and you guys also hit the
hotline with some so Jose here are a few
for you and just a few thoughts in
general in that he you know he was
worried about disappointing his father
was first-generation here in new America
you know and just a lot of what goes on
with that and what his life would look
like he wanted to start his own business
and here were some calls onward look the
Obama till today Nevada okay and this is
not the same Jose this is a different
Jose and I could easily make a no way
Jose joke here but I'm not gonna but I
just sort of inversely did right there
but this is not the same Jose who called
him with the problem homeward you know
this is for Jose so uh Phoenix Arizona
okay Thank You Jose for calling in about
about Jose Jose on first nope okay more
whatever story
I gotta say cause wasn't for me man I
was honestly tired of school sitting
down the damn desk but I said to the
corrected college I went for a full
semester back in 2016 I enjoyed it I
enjoyed learning being around
like-minded people opposed to the
finance girls but I realized I was gonna
spend a lot of time money and effort
there and I'm seen as was enough for at
the time back to 2016 toss that [ __ ]
I didn't go back no a few months later I
could be unimaginable
and I willed myself in therapy school
being like even starts papers okay so he
was in college he didn't like it that
much he liked the finance girls which
yeah I feel you bro
you know I don't know something about
college where women go there because
they you know they learn what they want
to learn and that's how you you know
that's how you get a woman with some
facts you got to lay some facts out on
the street when they show up you get out
there and bailar drop that bailamos on
them but here we go right here so but
now he's a massage therapy so you got a
massage therapy still catching with him
ladies beautiful homework I kept in mind
that this is gonna be bad complain
people [ __ ] in my life and yet honestly
so will paint job the point is if you
haven't done so you like both some way
about it I said finish your degree for a
backup to thank people [ __ ] you know a
good degree and what time or life
experience you'll find your likes
dislikes and talents beverage can it
being able to not be lazy and there you
go right there he's saying right there
take your time
he says he's saying get the degree take
your time
you know because you always have it as a
backup you know you can try something
different
take your time you have time you're
gonna slowly figure out your likes
dislikes and talents just don't be lazy
I like that let's hear another one came
in for you Jose here we go call for mr.
Ochoa the 21 and a half okay man just
get her done finish college I dropped
out when I was 19 and I regretted it for
the past nine years and you just got to
get in there and you
otherwise you're gonna end up signing
some other things to do with your time
you could hit the bottle or get into
drugs but just focus on a goal and just
get her done all right good luck to you
oh uh so fall as well boom there you go
that's some sound advice right there if
you're you know cuz there is one thing
man if I go back in time you know if
somebody showed up right now and they
had a big you know empty sack an empty
burlap sack and I and they and I said
hey hey mister what's in that sack there
and they said all any they said this is
a porthole back to time you know that's
the only time probably that I would
crawl up in a man's sack right there so
there you go you know finishing it up
there's something to be said for it
getting it done because yeah well idle
time that's the devil's diving-board
daddy and the devil will jump right off
of anything and land in the back of your
[ __ ] ball bag so there you go right
there
let's take one more they came in here we
go yes feel that Dean Justin I'm from
California
thanks for calling Justin homeward I'm
just responded at a fellow that is
decisions I've gone to college enough
and so I said like I'm going to another
I'm trying to finish that someone was
done
you know man it's tough you know because
you know these classes and stuff is a
lot of bureaucracy and so you don't take
these stupid class you know and take
them on it's not really about the
classes at the end of the day just about
meeting people and getting hanging out
with people I meet so many people and I
never wanna hang out with the same
people always think I was different
people explored myself man cuz you never
know who you meet you know the
connections are real people you need a
real good luck to you but man you may be
missing an opportunity of a lifetime man
and you know and that's a good point
because you ask anybody think you go
back to college who went to college most
people would say yes
most people gonna say yes I mean college
is a fun time you don't get that freedom
you don't get to be that free as you do
in college you know and I think that is
something special that's about you know
about being in like a four-year
university and getting that experience
of going and living on campus
you just don't get it again you don't
even get that time in your life when
because as you creep up an age people
just think there's more of expectations
on you from society and you might start
to feel that mr. Ochoa but but that's
you know there's some great there's some
great outlooks right there you know go
ahead get it done while you're there if
you already started finish it up dropped
out and regretted it you know it's not
even about the college it's about the
connections you know if you have a
business plan idea now you might meet
somebody in college who's got the other
side of it who's got the other side of
your business plan because if there's
anything that's tough to do is
everything by yourself you know teamwork
makes the dream work always you know you
want to you want to meet up with people
or a like mine didn't like to get things
done because you can't do it all you
know you need somebody to help with
everything this podcast I need people to
help with patreon the support we got um
we have our new camera being started up
this on Thursday's episode for the
coming up this week we got new lights
we're gonna be able to have a guest in
soon
you know I need an editor I got an
editor that's gonna come tonight and
take off with this footage and we'll but
we'll be up to midnight on the phone or
on skype discussing it you know but he's
he has to have that skill set I can't do
it all you know it's like there's a lot
of teamwork and you're gonna need that
man in a business idea a lot of times
maybe you won't but uh but but yeah
College is about the connections and the
opportunity and also do you get that I
mean they got a straight-up buffet off
of uh you know breasts or wiener out
there if you want it I mean college is
that time to cut up I mean out here in
the real world you can't even do you
can't be do anything anymore so if
you're gonna catch some extra you know
if you won't you know get into some
straight-up Special Olympics you know
what I'm saying if you're gonna just be
skating over somebody's you know over
that titty bar you know if you could
just gonna be you know you're gonna be
triple jumping some some [ __ ] on the
some you know up and down some ladies
you know leg or something then you're
gonna want to do something
you don't want to be at you're gonna
want to be in that College because you
can't just recreate college somewhere
you can't walk in like a you know a CVS
or a Walgreen and just you know say
let's turn the [ __ ] up
and start drinking and you know doing
shots out of people's eye asses if you
can't do all that you're gonna need a
real environment in college that you
know provides that last week we asked on
the episode I asked if any if any Boston
fans get tired of winning you know the
Patriots are gonna be in this final
again and and it's you know I think
everything loses its allure and even
victory probably does and this young
lady called in with some thoughts on
that here we go hey Theo my name is Jenn
you were saying on this past podcast you
were saying that people are getting
tired of Boston winning and you said you
heard a Patriots fans that they are
tired of seeing the Patriots win do we
feel greedy yeah it sometimes feels like
that I guess you could say okay thank
you for calling gin oh hey it doesn't I
bet it wouldn't feel as good at this
pace we saw the Saints win you know I'm
26 and the first time I saw Tom Brady
win a Super Bowl I was 11 years old or
something like that we were going
through some tough times like as a
family mm-hmm and Tom Brady's that man
and you know he's a six foot six that's
tall I mean that is tall that's like two
eight year olds long ways homeward and
while living the super 8 motel in this
crappy Brockton motel is some ghetto for
two months when we saw them when that
2002 Savoy I saw my dad cries eyes out
and like at that moment I realize like
how important this was for him at this
point in our lives how important it was
to play football
to bring us all together you know it did
it held our family together for such a
tough time
and I respect that and I appreciate that
call Jen you know that is a beautiful
moment I mean there's there's nothing
you know I mean it's there's also
nothing more Boston fan than you know a
dad crying in a Super eight motel with
his with his children as Tom Brady wins
a Super Bowl that's like the most you
know that's so real Boston you know not
fancy Boston I mean that's the you know
that's [ __ ] unbelievable you know
leaving the room to get you know hit the
ice machine by himself to have a few
moments and come back in and celebrate
you know crack open a thing of grape uh
you know maybe grape soda or something
for the kids or do something special you
know and yeah I mean that's Jesus Christ
a super8 two mountains they went out
those they were not doing well the last
I checked they were done in like a Super
Six and then and people were getting
murdered at some of them but I
appreciate the call and there is
something you know and I'm there is
something beautiful about there's
something beautiful about that there's
something beautiful about fan hood and
how it does it carries generations I
mean one thing I remember about about my
own father was watching Saints games and
he got me into him and and sometimes
you're a fan because someone else in
your family was it gives you a bridge
there gives you some sort of a
connection you know especially with
fathers and sons a lot of times there's
not a ton since men don't really relate
to each other very emotionally there's
not a lot of opportunities for this for
that emotional webbing between men and
there's and their sons so the fact that
they can share a sports team together is
huge and it really does you know there
was nothing more that that my my
grandfather wanted to see them then the
Cubs win you know and he could used to
blow cigarette smoke in my face and
cheat at cards when we were children
he took a big hit off that Marlboro red
or you know he back there just blowing
him Winston's and he'd hit me with a big
I mean I couldn't see or my eyes were
burning he would cheat at cards but he
loved the Chicago Cubs
and for most of my life I've loved him
you know and when they when they won I
cried I cried because I didn't really
cry you know I cried something for me
but really I cried for him probably you
know it was it just welled up in me that
a lot of his life this had been
something he loved and that's one thing
that's kind of beautiful about humanity
is sometimes you know if sometimes we
carry out the dreams or the moments of
those who went before us you know and I
guess that's kind of a neat thing where
I mean that's kind of a neat rivet in in
who we are is I got this that's kind of
an escape from our ego when we have
moments like that you know when
something special happens and it's yeah
we're there we're happy there to see it
but I really you know I'm the eyes of my
of my grandfather at that point or
there's a little bit of him in my heart
where I see you know I'm in moding
feeling emotion because he would be if
he could be alive and there's a moment
where there is you for you as a child
and that's super8 you know where you you
know you see your father have feelings
and sports will do that I guess it's you
know it is it's a unique it's a unique I
want to say it's a conduit for our
feelings but it's a it's a it's it's a
unique quilt you know that we that we
find our space in and that connects a
lot of people and [ __ ] I don't know the
[ __ ] I'm talking about doing Jesus
Christ bro I don't know if I'm [ __ ]
or not but sports does that sometimes
it's the catalyst for behavior you know
it's a catalyst for connectivity it's a
catalyst for
you know it gives us a chance to compete
against someone else or even to cheer
our favorite competitors on you know
it's that it's such a conduit for a lot
of of our emotions you know it really
really is but I appreciate that call Jen
I appreciate that call what else is
going on oh I got this call that came in
to me and this is a question directed at
me and I'm a new uh to get to this when
I know I'm just kind of jumping through
calls here guys
I don't know what's calling so I'm just
feeling weird today or what you know uh
I don't know it's Sunday I just I don't
know I don't feel that just I don't know
I mean I feel like physically fine I
just this is not you know just feeling
whatever let's say so so let's keep this
going here we go what's going on yeah we
had a question I asked you and this is
Andre out of Boston hitting that hotline
here we go Dre yeah that's uh Chris
Perez out there we got a Latino
gentleman here doing that and he's um
he's unique specimen you're pretty shy
but we might have him on soon let's see
um Burton
do you consider yourself a Latin fella
considering you have Nicaraguan because
I mean I was born in America and I'm
Cuban and showing my mother Chile am i -
in Cuba damn you that Chilean Cuban huh
oh boy damn you sound like a fancy order
of fish at one of those nice restaurants
man that Chilean Cuban dude man it sound
like I'd have if I owned you I'd have
you in a tank you know and that reminds
that you my sister and her husband have
a fit of bass in a tank at their house
right and it can't even turn around it's
just in there moving a little bit cuz
it's gotten so big it can't barely you
know turn around in the tank but it is
in the tank
homeward Andre homeward say your father
some nicaragua so do you consider
yourself latin american because i mean
you kind of come up with some
stereotypical [ __ ] sometimes
I just kind of take you as well no not
that it matters but I'm just curious
Gang Gang bruh bailar you know what I'm
saying
do I consider myself Latin American but
hey I'll tell you this man i'ma tell you
this
my father was straight about that
Nicaragua and where my Nick guards at
where my real neat cars and he you know
he lived there till he was 14 and he
came over to to New Orleans or to
America United States of America and he
used to talk a lot in Spanish man I
don't know what the [ __ ] he was talking
about because I was a child you know and
he was also he was 70 when I was born -
by the time we got to really talking
he's about 80 you know so he coming in
kind of with that 80 year old
perspective you know slaying that
espanol around the house and I didn't
really get to feel him that much you
know and feel that vibe of him you know
he took me one time - I think porta
viar-toe one time he took me there to do
something and he might have been
involved in some shady activity actually
because he used to go back and forth
between Central American and America
Estados Unidos and I think he might have
been involving a little bit of shady
[ __ ] and I don't know what an 80 year
old man can get involved in that shady
you know probably not drug muling or
anything like that maybe running a
little bit of small bags of coke or
something I don't know
I mean he was caught up in a little bit
of the dark arts right there and I knew
even as a child that something was you
know a little bit wild going on but did
I feel it no because I didn't feel much
from my father you know I remember him
he told me obviously you know uh you
know he told me that I was a survivor he
told me that I that I had the heart of a
lesbian he'd always told me that since I
was young
cuz I had that vibrant heart you know
and I got hit by that Trans Am and
survived it and he told me um you know
he told me that I'd be okay you know I
think he kind of started to kind of
prepare me for the fact that he wasn't
gonna be around forever
he got me my firt he got me into doing
stand-up comedy really when I think
about it my father used to be that guy
he used to go to you know he's involved
in some crazy [ __ ] and he you know he
bought a Cutlass 88 off a couple of
brothers and it had speakers in the back
but he didn't mind the speakers because
he was hard of hearing so he'd be
rolling through the you know through the
town through our neighborhood and stuff
you know what a couple of 12s in the
back just do you know just killing them
but with some whatever they were six
teens I don't know what they were but he
couldn't hear but he had that bass so
he'd be listening like NPR or all these
political talk shows Rush Limbaugh or
something and just Paul Harvey you know
he had that and one of the speakers I
remember was blown out and some Chinese
food got stuck in it and he used to
rattle bruh it's sounding like a huge
[ __ ] rattlesnake in the back of that
trunk and my dad had that you know and
he had you know and he was still trying
to make some money because him and my
mother were always fighting he had to
make some money to survive but did he
did I feel you know I remember kids in
our neighborhood would call me a [ __ ]
all the time because you know my brother
and I and my sisters had you know kind
of a little bit of tan skin and for our
neighborhood for our town we had very
tan skin you know it was very I mean you
almost after us was just black you know
there wasn't a lot of middle grade going
on so in it you didn't have a lot of
mixed people back then you did have a
lot of mulatto people you don't have a
lot of black white people and some
people get upset at these kind of terms
whatever man you know I'm talking about
wouldn't have a lot of people that were
mixed it wasn't as popular then you know
you didn't have people with a black and
a white parent or a black and a you know
and those were we only had a couple of
ethnicities you know so you know I
didn't feel it you know my father would
tell me stories a lot about growing up
you know and he talked about they didn't
have a lot of money growing up he talked
about the poverty that was in the
country you know his family was down
there they worked in a church and they
were building a church and it might
still be there I'm not sure I plan to go
back sometimes but I think what it did
do it inspired me to do a couple of
things you know it's inspired me to try
and learn Spanish it's inspired me to
I'd like to do a special in Spanish one
day to be able to perform
you know for people that catch that
Latino vibe you know for anybody that's
ever been Latino or anybody that's ever
you you know been kidnapped and you know
in you know Bolivia or somewhere or you
know one of those drug countries or
something like that or any you know a
little bit of homage so it makes me
think like that but you know I guess
I've always felt maybe just a little bit
obscure a little bit different I know
that when I speak Spanish said it really
comes out I mean naturally you know it
comes out of here like it's supposed to
be in me you know it's like when you
open up a tube of toothpaste you see
toothpaste in the tube and it makes
sense to you that's how I feel about
that Latin culture that vibe you know
but I remember my father doing some
shady [ __ ] man when I was young he'd be
cooking [ __ ] bananas in the front
yard and [ __ ] like that you know and
some of you don't know how much of it
was Latino and how much of it was just
the fact that he was in his 80s and he
was starting to lose his mind and he had
a griddle so it's a lot of mixed stuff
going on but he you know he wrote for a
lot of some newspapers down there and
you know I guess so it's in my blood I
feel like it's in my it's in my nature
and it's in my nurture I think it's in
both of those things so that's what's up
man yeah I mean I guess I do stay a
little bit on the surface maybe some
stereotypical stuff but I would do some
stuff for uh you know for another
country man I'd do something for my
fellow Nicaraguans you know I mean I'm
gonna think our drug mule or anything
you know
I mean honestly I'd probably if I put a
couple grams up my bum I'd probably hope
they'd bust so I get that free hit and
his wouldn't count as relapsing you know
whereas you know it's not being sober so
I might you know poke the bag with a
needle or something for I'll put that
you know that sweet white unicorn up my
buttocks but anyhow it's a good question
man and I appreciate it that's a good
question I appreciate it what else dude
we got another couple of good calls that
came in I want to let you guys first
know of course about zip recruiter com
say you have you need somebody
and this ain't a dating site this is a
site for employment employers looking
for quality employees because it's hard
out there you know I'm saying you can't
just drive down the street and pick up a
hitchhiker and you know and and they get
in the car and they can do all the
things that you want them to be able to
do they can type you know 80 words per
minute and you know they can they know
how to you know they know how to the
different templates for different
documents it's not like the old days you
know the old days you pick up a
hitchhiker next next thing you know they
have a skill they built you a house or
they you know they've been watching your
children for a couple years but not
anymore now if you want quality employee
you need to use zip recruiter com
here's what it does zip recruiter you
put what you need out there
zip recruiter sends it out to tons of
websites who are looking for people and
also it pulls in people who are looking
for similar type work it finds the best
of those that creme de la crosse and
sends them right back to you so you got
that crop Krim in your inbox right there
suddenly you're only looking through ten
or twelve people maybe to find who's the
best because the thousands of candidates
have already been looked through by zip
recruiter calm and you can try zip
recruiter for free by going to zip
recruiter dot-com slash t pw
use-it-or-lose-it if you got a job
fill it try it for free what do you got
to lose huh what do you have to lose a
failing business by making it better
that's all you got to lose try zip
recruiter com all right let's get into a
little bit of stuff man here we go we
got another call right here that came in
and I want to I want to get to that now
here we go
I just got a little problem going on my
wife recently started drinking like a
couple weeks ago okay this gentleman
called in and I didn't get a name there
but his wife recently started drinking a
couple weeks ago more her getting
hammered drunk she wasn't with me she's
with their cousin and she ended up
texting the boy that she
hook up hmm so she just started drinking
and her first night getting really drunk
she texted a boy she used to hook up
with more but then last night on New
Year's Eve she got pretty drunk again at
my brother's house we ended up having
sex in the house like whatever Oh yet
sexy your brother's house - that's wild
so tricky so goofy dude and silly okay
more then later she ended up hooking up
with my sister-in-law wait what is a
sister-in-law that is your brother's
wife no dude if you and your brother end
up banging or dating dude or touching
each other aggressively that is crazy
bro and some places it's illegal some
places it's not illegal I think if you
go on a boat and go off the coast a
little bit I think if to be at least you
know 300 yards out or something um more
after like my brother went to bed she
just went downstairs
my sister-in-law literally she did boom
had to put that one in there more I
ended up hooking up selling each other's
private parts you know oh oh yeah dude
touching that little thermostat bro I
know what you're talking about you know
I'm saying
whoo that CUDA it's kind of bugging me
is this is that something that every guy
wants right just why she being the chick
- I have him but also I feel like a
little bit rate I'm just wondering what
everyone thinks I should do about the
situation or your thoughts on it
like should I be bad I just let it go
how do I handle this situation that's a
good question how would I handle the
situation if my wife hooked up with my
brother's wife
well dude I'll be look here's how this
is gonna end up and this is an advice
but this is just what's going to happen
is it's going to end up that you guys
are gonna start expecting it and you
guys are gonna end up probably having
sex with each other's wives or jerking
off while they're hooking up somewhere
and if you think there's a safe in some
people it's not just gonna end up we all
gonna end up giggling about this during
a game of uno you know or playing
Foursquare to get Foursquare together
and laughing about it that's not gonna
happen what's gonna happen is this is
gonna escalate and you're gonna see
these people a lot because it's your
brother and his wife unless something
happens to them or something happens to
you guys you know unless there's a crime
and you guys are victims of a crime or
they are you're gonna continue to see
them a lot and this stuff's gonna
escalate and next thing you know D y'all
gonna be buying toys and it's gonna get
uh it's gonna get exciting honestly you
know and I wish you know my brother and
his wife they got a lot going on and I
don't have a wife and it's you know and
I don't know if I don't want that for
myself my family couldn't handle that
but for you it sounds like you're
getting out there you know and I don't
know I mean if people have thought - you
guys gonna the hotline ninety five six
six four nine five zero three and we'll
get to it if you have thoughts for this
gentleman his wife has hooked up with
his sister-in-law this wild brother that
is wild
let's take one more call here and this
is from Andrea I see right here onward
hey Co this is Andrea from Arizona my
question for you is thanks for calling
Andrea Moore at your age not saying
you're old or anything but at your age
do you feel like you need to be married
and have kids like do you feel that type
of pressure and do you even want that
just curious
oh it's a good question you know I do
want most of the time I want children
you know most of the time I do worry
that I wouldn't be able to handle it you
know I do worry
that I would not be able to be faithful
to my spouse I do worry that I would be
caught in a situation where I am you
know I have a family and and you know
and and things don't work out with the
wife and then I have to let my kid down
because his parents aren't married in
anymore so I think that those were a lot
of things that you know it's and that's
fear
a lot of that's just you know things
that I fear that really scares me some
of those things I love children you know
I talked to my niece today and she
auditioned to be in the school play in
Louisiana and just hearing the
excitement in her voice and what her
life is like and how everything sounds
like so big and had a little how the
little things are so important to her
and just hearing a little person talk to
you you know there's a lot of like
little joys there you know III I you
know I want to be I want to be able to
make sure that I'm healthy enough to put
make sure my kids have an emotionally
stable environment and that's and some
people had called in a few weeks ago
about some of that kind of stuff about
you know things you could instill in
your son if you had if you had a son for
a woman that was about to have her sec
second kid a lot of people called him
and had some suggestions for her but
yeah I would like it you know I would
like it I think I just have some fears
you know when sometimes I still don't
want to grow up that's the hard part you
know I don't know how much of that of me
not wanting to grow up is just my fear
like reshaping itself and representing
itself to me as that you know my fear of
commitment like I don't know all of that
could just be the same thing it just
keeps reshaping and showing up again but
it's tough you know it's tough it's
tough you know I live in an environment
here in Los Angeles is not a lot of
examples of that so to go in in in and
do
and get healthy in that way in a healthy
relationship and healthy marriage it's
it's it's obtuse for what's happening
out here
so you just I'm not saying that that's
wrong or anything but you have a lot of
examples of that's not what's happening
but I think there's an ideal inside of
me that I would love to have a you know
a loving wife that I am able to love and
support I'd like to have some children
you know that that feel connected to me
not to just you know that it seems like
I'm connected but really that I can
connect with and that they know that I
care and I and you know and I'd like to
be able to have a home where you know
maybe do some foster family I mean I
think about a lot of stuff like that you
know and I know that I have enough like
love inside of me for that kind of stuff
I just don't know sometimes if I can
fend off my own dark arts you know a my
own you know hold myself together enough
to get through it but I'm hopeful you
know I'm hopeful and I hope that if I
stay in the you know in environments
where I'm learning from other men and
and thinking about this kind of stuff
and answering questions like this that
you know I will that my brain and heart
will you know continue to get to know
each other better and find a comfortable
ground where they are sure and confident
that they'll be able to get me through
not just me but my family through those
times you know a lot of it's the ego
honest you know my ego is dangerous my
ego can be dangerous and I got to get my
self-worth a little bit better you know
I mean that's one of my problems
sometimes I feel like you know some of
the both of those things and it's crazy
to have one at the same time as the
other you know to have like a to have
like a you know bit of ego mania and an
inferiority complex at the same time you
know but that's sometimes where my brain
is man it'll you know it's just it's a
little mixed up but it's it's evening
out but I appreciate that question and I
appreciate the the episode and I
appreciate you guys being here
everything I feel like this episode was
all over the place but sometimes AR
what's going on with me not much else
anything else I got to do just tell you
guys thank you and just let you guys
know that I'll see you this Thursday and
also subscribe on youtube if you haven't
subscribed go ahead and subscribe when
we get to 30 thousands subscribers I'm
going to put out a new comedy clip that
you guys haven't seen and I'll probably
also put it out one day if we don't get
there but I'd like to get there continue
to hit the hotline if you have any
thoughts about this episode nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
you guys be good to yourselves you
probably deserve it
I'm a tired wait am i even know what I
am or just something let us don't know
what I am
celebrate
[Music]
know that soon but thank you guys for
being here with me today I think I
needed uh I think I needed that